présidente de la république je vais
revivifier nos institutions et notre
fonctionnement démocratique
tout d'abord par le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
emmanuel macron semble prêt à revoir son
projet d'âge de la retraite à 65 ans je
suis prêt à bouger le rapport au temps
c'est donc à dire on fait pas forcément
une réforme pour jusqu'à 2030 on sent
trop d'emplois s'il n'y a pas d'accord
là dessus que je sens sa crise peu trop
je suis prêt à avoir des clauses de
revoyure plutôt pour des retraites avant
et les gens auront décidé l'instauration
du septennat non renouvelable qui rendra
à la fonction présidentielle son
prestige et au président sa capacité
d'une action longue tout en le
débarrassant d'une obligation de
campagne électorale permanente je suis
plutôt favorable au septennat moi j'ai
toujours tendance à penser que le
caractère renouvelable non renouvelables
ça dépend du peuple emmanuel macron qui
a reçu ce matin le soutien de nicolas
sarkozy l'ancien président votera pour
lui ils l'expliquent en disant je crois
qu'il a l'expérience nécessaire face à
une grave crise internationale plus
complexe que jamais je le remercie de sa
confiance et de son soutien je pense que
c'est très important et que salam au
nord et ça m'oblige j'étais étonné
qu'ils le fassent qu'au second tour je
matin je croyais qu'il le ferait dès le
premier voyez donc comme quoi il a quand
même fait preuve d'un minimum d'élégance
à l'égard de valérie pécresse il a fait
un choix de circonstance parce qu'il a
fait le juge qui traînent encore dans le
coin et le fait de choisir macron peut
peut-être les éloigner s'étant jamais
vous pensez qu'il espère en retour
d'ascenseur je me demande si je vais pas
finir par faire des affiches parce que
rien que nicolas sarkozy et le
luxembourg appel à battre marine le pen
je pense que ça peut débloquer des voix
pour moi je mettrais mois pour m'opposer
à marine le pen à butten macron dans
l'urne ça ne vaut ni caution ni adhésion
ni ni soutient madame le pen raconte
comme d'habitude des carabistouilles
vous traduirez même en anglais et
voilà pourquoi elle explique qu'elle
paiera pas la facture du club qu'elle en
changera les règles mais qui n'en
changera y tout seul il y en a qui ont
essayé ils ont eu des problèmes mon
objectif n'est pas de baisser la
contribution à l'union européenne mais
de baisser la contribution nette réelle
est actuellement à 1 9 milliard je
souhaiterais qu'elle soit à 4 milliards
ce qui est en réalité la moyenne de ce
qu'elle était cette contribution nette
sous jacques chirac certains sortent
tout de même le chéquier pour un montant
de 0 euros heureusement un ancien
concurrent vole à son secours un don de
jean lassalle avec en cadeau un conseil
on a souvent besoin d'un plus petit que
soi y a pas de journée chez quotidien
un an mais pardon si c'est que quotidien
si elle que ça non quotidiens c1 c'est
pas c'est pas d'une émission de 2
d'information ou de journalistes
quotidien c'est un amuseur parfois très
drôle d'ailleurs manche dit pas et c'est
une émission de divertissement et
j'avais moins chéquier et on l'a fait et
alors
officier ça sert à rien sur le
relationnel des asociaux ah bon donc il
a mis sur le social voilà comment se
fait un don vraiment
participer le tout voilà de toute quête
deux fois
oui voyez chez moi ben oui mais vous
savez je suis chez chez moi donc dans
mon qg est dans mon mouvement monsieur
de libération qui a toujours eut été
accueillis d'ailleurs en toutes
circonstances les pécresse peut aussi
compter sur le soutien de l'ancien
trader jérôme kerviel un temps d'été à
hauteur de 5 milliards d'euros je ne me
sentais pas obligé d'accréditer
quotidien même
si j'ai un crédit l'ensemble des autres
y compris bien entendu des médias qui
sont extrêmement hostile comme vous